dan
do you have a question
sorry about that
um tia i'm sorry uh russ a lot of times
with your misses like when when you know
they're bad misses they get a lot of
attention and stuff how are you able to
not process like
you know the myth before the end of the
game right like that shot
it's kind of high off the backboard like
how do you not let that stuff affect
your confidence
oh
[Music]
i got 23 000 points
how about that
it's a good answer
um
can you describe what what you were
feeling as you were running there's a
picture of you running by drake and
drake's got his mouth wide open and
you're screaming out after you hit that
dream three what's going through your
head yeah i know my wife just sent me
that picture just now oh uh excitement
i'm seeing actually seeing my teammates
uh see bazemore on the floor i see my
guys super excited that's uh the only
thing i'm looking at as a as you know
after i turn back down
um and the other thing i want to ask you
there was a video that went viral this
morning it looked like a fan was was
yelling at you on the street um i know
you talked about how how hard things
have been on your family this season
what what happened last night yeah i
mean it's over i moved past it um
and we move on if you have anything
related to basketball then we can talk
about if not we can move on
thank you kyle
harris um avery was describing this
feeling on defense um
where he just felt like guys were more
locked in than they had been recently
and playing for each other was the words
he used um did you feel that also and
where do you think some of that
transformation has come from recently
yeah you know we had a better start um
as you you know guys seen i think
defensively um and we made some open
shots which helps too when you have a
ability better make open looks um to
start the game and
like everyone said
i thought we did a great job of just
sticking to our principles
you know grinding the game out this is a
grind out game especially a team that's
been really hot and they won by five
straight so
to be able to to know that we're capable
of doing it
like we know we are especially when guys
are out and guys stepping up it's a big
thing for us
it's important now we can hopefully get
some momentum moving into tomorrow night
last question bt
russ with the way this season has gone
to get this win tonight against a very
good team like toronto
what was it feeling like in the locker
room
um you know honestly guys are it's crazy
because yes you know you think that we
should be like super hyped but like
we know as a unit what we're capable of
and yes it feels good to to break out i
mean i think we lost 11 straight on the
road to break that streak yes that feels
great but we also know
um what our capabilities are and how we
can be able to use this wind to be able
to